dans ses bureaux de l'association
gérontologique des yvelines les deux
psychologues qui travaillent répondent à
environ 250 appels chaque année la
nature et les causes de ces appels
maltraitances physiques psychologiques
ou encore financière sur des personnes
âgées
la première partie du travail celle
écoute qui est très importante puisqu'il
s'agit de qualifier la maltraitance de
voir les différents interlocuteurs
intervenants professionnels qui peuvent
sont susceptibles d'être déjà dans la
situation et après il s'agit de mettre
la personne si c'est un particulier en
lien avec le professionnel de terrain ce
professionnel ira ensuite à la rencontre
de la victime supposée pour mettre en
action les outils des travailleurs
sociaux
un dispositif baptisé m avait 78 qui
s'inscrit dans la lutte contre la
maltraitance des adultes vulnérables les
appels sur la plateforme yvelines 192 en
176 en 2015 nous sommes le troisième
département de france qui remonte au
temps dans 55% des cas de maltraitance
est un proche
c'est à dire les enfants le conjoint ou
le reste de la famille une augmentation
des violences en institution a été
constaté par l'association ces deux
dernières années une campagne de
sensibilisation est lancée par le
département en direction du grand public
c'est trop tabou il faut il faut que les
gens sachent qu'il faut dénoncer ces
situations on fait maltraitance envers
anvers tous est un parent proche sans
vouloir par négligence et donc c'est
aussi important d'être sensibilisés à
une façon d'être maltraitant qui n'est
pas dont on n'a pas conscience
c'est la cinquième année consécutive que
le contrat entre l'association et le
département est renouvelée pour une aide
d'un budget de 180 mille euros